so in an objective sense this was an
absolutely disastrous weekend for Donald
Trump but I want to try to think about
it from the perspective of the average
Trump Estill EFT recognizing that Donald
Trump has failed again doesn't really do
much for us we're already not voting for
the guy in November of 2020 so let's
review number one
Donald Trump has had to abandon pushing
a question about citizenship into the
2020 census the pressure became too
great the risk of delaying the census
altogether grew too large courts were
deciding against Donald Trump
so Trump is bailed out by saying you
know what we're not going to keep going
with the citizenship question on the
census but he tried to kind of save face
by saying well we can get the
citizenship information from existing
federal records of course why not just
plan to do that from the beginning if
it's so easy to get that information
from records that already exist but a
definitive and total failure by Donald
Trump another failure over the weekend
is that Donald Trump's Labor Secretary
has been forced to resign over his
involvement in what was arguably immoral
and potentially criminal involvement in
a plea deal for accused sex trafficker
and rapist
and Trump friend Jeffrey Epstein now I'm
not not actually saying that Alexander
Acosta Trump's now resigned or soon
resigning labor secretary is going to be
convicted of any crime for his
involvement in that plea deal that's not
how it works there's an immunity for
prosecutors who participate in this way
but there is a case to be made that what
took place violates multiple principles
of how the justice system is supposed to
operate by law what took place is that
Alexander Acosta back when in Florida he
was handling Jeffrey Epstein's sex
crimes case struck a just ridiculous
plea deal in 2008 and the pressure also
started to mount an Acosta is leaving
which ups the number of currently acting
cabinet secretaries to four which is
just absolutely ridiculous the inability
to fill important positions by the Trump
administration is really an internal
crisis
is not being covered nearly the to the
extent that it should so by any
objective measure terrible weekend
losing another cabinet secretary the
controversy around Jeffrey Epstein it
continues to inch closer and closer to
Donald Trump himself remember that Trump
is accused of raping the same
thirteen-year-old girl that accused
Jeffrey Epstein as well and he gives up
one of his big red meat nationalist
ideas of the citizenship question on the
census but we all know that this is
another failure another set of failures
by Donald Trump
we already weren't voting for them so
what we really need to do is dive into
how the average Trump astiz going to see
this and this is really important okay
the failure on some parts of the left to
think about the Trump campaign as a
right winger would see it back in 2016
was a big blind spot and we don't want
to do this again in 2020 at rumpus is
going to see Trump's failure to get the
citizenship question into the census as
Trump just being held down by liberal
activist judges and they will say see we
told you
this proves that nobody other than Trump
cares about immigration Trump wants to
keep us safe he's great and all of these
liberal activist judges are preventing
Donald Trump from securing the United
States from immigrants a trumpet will
see the labor secretary resignation once
again as that oppressive regressive
leftist mob that's bullying people and
is intolerant and is forcing them out
just to hurt Donald Trump now what I've
just told you is laughable to a
clear-thinking person but the trumpets
will see it and will be emboldened by
this so these things aren't going to
move the needle in the battle to remove
Donald Trump in the next election now
also just a funny and bizarre moment
Donald Trump in a public statement that
he made defending Alexander Acosta just
says Alexander Acosta is Hispanic like
as part of the defense basically saying
hey I had a Hispanic guy how great is
that take a look at this Alex called me
this morning anyone
see me and I actually said well we have
to press right out here so perhaps you
just want to say it to the press but I
just want to let you know this was him
not me because I'm with them
he was a he's a tremendous talent he's a
Hispanic man he went to Harvard
a great student I didn't want him to
resign
he's smart and he's Hispanic but the
most telling thing is that Donald Trump
feels bad for Acosta
okay Acosta participated in brokering a
disgusting plea deal
a normal person would see the situation
and they would say wow I feel really bad
for Epstein's victims who saw Epstein
get a ridiculously lakhs deal of I think
it was 13 months and I don't know
exactly how much of that he ultimately
served and instead Trump feels bad for
the attorney who had the gall to strike
such a ridiculous and immoral plea deal
with a predator the likes of Jeffrey
Epstein these are really dark times
everything is backwards but if we ignore
it if we just say hey I'm a leftist here
are my values here's how I react to what
Donald Trump is doing we're missing the
boat that's not going to help us win in
2020 and we need to win I want to win so
we've got to be thinking about these
things in terms of how will a trump Asst
see and interpret them and I'm going to
continue trying to do that as we get
closer and closer to the 2020 election